[Music]
[Music]
these microphones working now it's the
most wonderful time of the nice working
I feel like I never get I don't know you
tell us chat is it one into I'm new to
this one and two up oh here we go that's
my voice hi hi hi hi welcome back to
Triforce we're doing it we're doing it
it's been a while
I'm Peter Browns Rob handler II we like
to play Zelda and there's more Zelda to
place so we are going to play it with
you guys dude there's a hell of a lot of
Zelda happening cut the gameplay there
we go
I'm sure you all know the Game Awards
last night Nintendo announced that the
battle of the champions DLC out and it
is out I've been some I have gotten
through a couple of the shrines that pop
up you've gotten through a little bit
more you rep until 3 a.m. like a crazy
person I feel a little crazy right now
dude maybe turn on the gameplay just a
little bit you know let's get this all
out of the way so so gosh word I
actually kind of blacked out last night
in a way where like I just played until
I I just literally like walked away from
my desk and just passed out so I don't
know exactly where I left off so let's
take a look so what I know that you're
at is for those of you who are playing
this DLC and again we're gonna be just
playing it so granted there will be
spoilers but yeah we're all experiencing
this together so hang in there so
anyways this what I'm doing right now
basically I feel like the first part is
like these intro trials where you're
given that like four pronged I don't
know spatula
whatever the hell that giant thing is
it's as far as I'm aware it's got these
like it's sort of like Shinto esque
[Music]
ornaments hanging off of it basically
yeah it's meant to be sort of like a
spiritual type of type of thing
reflecting the four champions right so
you get through four shrines and they're
very
called and that weapon can kill enemies
in one hit
more or less it's like an insane there's
how the catch is that you have a quarter
of a heart so you basically any any any
damage you to anything yeah anything
that's what having you a behavior old
environment yeah you're done so it's
difficult but then you get through those
four shrines and this is where I'm at so
I've done a couple of these things and
I'd like to say that you're kind of now
in another series of four going to each
region that the champions are from so
I'm at your bow says like area and I and
I did these more or less than three
challenges so you know they're in the
riddle form that Moses Elda things are
so it's fight uproot in the sand so it
was this giant mold ago well how do you
say that goddamn name your clothes will
do good well Duga well do you got an old
dear gap she was a beard a beaut anyways
I think I did that so now I'm at gosh I
marked them chased the Rings I'm oh so
that was like you get a on a sand seal
and you do like a little bit of race and
now I'm at yeah it's kind of cool and
now I'm at throw the orb underground I'm
pretty sure so you know I do that right
so over here was this shrine that had
paintings on it and it roughly showed us
you know a little fraction of the map
and its it's like a it's a it was
actually kind of difficult painting to
look at but this is where I matter now
so I think I with I think it was over
here and I'm winging it and yeah this is
gonna take a while so far I have to say
I'm enjoying this more than the first
yeah bout a DLC I agree
no the sword trials all that stuff
mastered like master mode is an
incredible addition and the trials of
the sword we're also pretty cool but
there's something about being able to
like even though you're on the brink of
death for like half of this thing you do
still have all your equipment so you
don't feel like totally robbed of all
the progress you've made in the past
yeah which I like and skill is still
very much important because yeah you
will die almost immediately I got this
so late last night
yeah nope it was 9:00 and then like I
had some internet problems here or more
like internet stupidity on my end and
like it took like half an hour to
download and I had to get home basically
man I almost want to go back to this map
area cuz I don't do you think let's do
that just end that plus I actually kinda
wanna show it how do you feel about the
motorcycle I know there's some people in
the chat and a lot of people on Twitter
are sort of like boom owning that
arrival as something that maybe doesn't
really fit I I initially had that
feeling but then I looked at it in the
vein of like a lot of DLC for any kind
of game maybe there's a way they can
sell it story-wise
I mean there's okay but I don't I don't
really care because I've played this
game so much that that just seems like a
really fun thing I mean it sounds it
sounds and and it is out of place but
then I feel a bit but but is it though
is that's the thing I don't I don't
think so because you have these spider
robots crawling around totally right
like machinery is to be had in this area
yeah yes
now how there's only like one motorcycle
in the world right where that would be a
very big invention you would imagine
which basically inventing the wheel I
like was thing about it like just going
up to a stable with that thing Oh God
would you like to register your horse
[Laughter]
the hell is that holy God bill look at
this
have you ever i think it's right think
it's cool i think it is - i as much as i
love like getting envelops and embedded
in the immersive like moments of this
game it's also just a platform for weird
experimentation and just like strange
events so it doesn't like personally
speaking I don't think that it it breaks
the world even logically or just you
know atmospherically for me it feels
cool and and frankly when I think about
what that might change about how I go
about like I'm really stoked yeah Oh
totally like I just you know one of my
favorite things about watchdogs to a
game that had some good qualities some
not-so-good qualities one of my favorite
things was riding around a motorcycle in
that game because they really nailed the
feel of it and it kind of made me like
and that's a thing in Grand Theft Auto
as well that feels great and so seeing
that pop up here just maybe you remember
that how fun a motorcycle can be just
because they're so maneuverable right
and goes so fast and and you think about
the terrain and Zelda - and and I'm I'm
happy they don't they also in this DLC
they don't just give it to you yeah
you got to work for that [ __ ] and you I
think you know is that you have to have
all the divine beasts done but anyways
let's go shouts you skin Vic marks for
reminding us to talk to chat because you
know what I don't scream that much
anymore and I forget these things thanks
for the shoutout
you got a [ __ ] and thank you guys for
joining us once again it is fun to be
back and Rob I'm showing you these
paintings alright so here here's what I
was talking about earlier so it's just
three of these things so this is where
that mold agha mold ooga ooga do-don't I
hate some of the names I just can't get
to some these I can't remember some of
these anyways no mold a guy plural so no
actually was yeah that's right and then
that was the race one so this is where
we're trying to go here okay this one I
this is where my mind just crapped out
last night and I couldn't pinpoint off
so I was close actually so this is
definitely where the
Kling hideout my hideout is that's
that's where I was at so it's like
alright so here's like that little
bridge I think I was like right here and
I and I got the the placement wrong so
it's more towards this opening have been
any speedrunners I don't know if you've
had a chance to look Josh was saying
that there speedrunners last night but
like I guess at this point who have oh
wait acquired the bike and everything Oh
God so that's the devs do I I have to I
have to do this on my own I gotta find
that bike I want to see him for myself
you know what I mean sure so the quicker
I can get there the better so then I
don't have to like unplug the Internet
so this looks like that bridge and the
quest was throw the orb underground I
don't know about you but I feel like
there's a giant hole here spin that
however you want I don't give a [ __ ] I
think I think this is what there was to
go by you yeah am i right I think I'm
right yes you're right this market all
right how can we get there goodness rob
Farex decant the twitch chat is enjoying
our hijinks and mispronounced words and
I got to say I love mispronounced words
yeah totally intentional
I love intentionally mispronouncing
words yes okay I think this is good here
all right the coop took our shrine
remember that one know these names man
Byron Maguire and the YouTube chat is
asking about shrines there are four new
ones right unless I'm missing any yeah
like so far there have been stages to
this like DLC as far as you know all the
new content there so far there have been
like four shrines which we explained
earlier they're like similar in that
they're like they're limiting your
abilities like you have low health but
you have a really cool weapon that can
do one-hit kills those are once they are
having trials the
like the four initial ones now there
seemed this is the first one I've done
of the now another four which is like
these maps and the shrines that are in
the areas of respected champions right
okay so eight shrines that we know of so
far and then as it's been confirmed a
new divine beast yeah I think it's it's
like yeah I think there's gonna be three
parts to this I think this is like when
you complete these four ones you're
gonna unlock this dungeon I feel like
because they're in the trailer there was
something you know rising out of the
ground I am just a little bit sad
oh no obviously privileged but a little
bit sad that I have to review this
because I have got a through it this
weekend and I would just love to take my
time sure I'm at the I'm at the point
where like every time I open this game
up again it's like distraction well it's
like do I want to start over like do I
want to do this all over again because
it's just such a magical [ __ ] game it
really is yeah I've never had I've never
played a game that is as magical as this
for sure but yeah that was a different
kind of magic black magic all right
I'm stalling alright so I'm in the
twitch chat i if you needed a reason to
buy the switch this this is definitely I
had yeah and like when it came out
obviously this was the only game you
could have on the switch and still I was
fighting the urge to say like it's all
you need though like biting my tongue
because I actually like do think that
but now you have plenty of other reasons
to to invest I I think it's it's
fantastic playing this thing on the go
only three perch ampion for in the
plateau krob there are
13 insurance according to Johnny and
Dean Jesus and I'm getting orbs -
actually I forgot about that you're
getting orbs so like burn oh wait oh
wait three weeks ahead four champions
that would be bottom you know I was
getting sixteen news Ryan's whole damn I
could get a new heart because that's
what's interesting is like actually if
you you like in the main game you can't
have full hearts and full stamina
let's show now I think they're kind of
like allowing you to max out a fish get
your heart on show you dog yes so how
many frames per second as many frames as
the game needs I don't know it's like
sixty sometimes thirty um I can't matter
it's over here where's my marker what
you get to zoom out in this mode right
here this scope
where's the goddamn marker one of the
things I really liked about Xenoblade
Chronicles 2 or the camera controls like
on the fly you could pull the camera way
out or you could go so close in that you
were in first-person mode and you can
just seamlessly just sort of like pull
in and out of that mmm it made like
popping this in last night and playing
for the first time in a while I was like
oh crap we're teaming I don't have those
controls I really wanted them playing
Mario and this was always frustrating
going back and forth cuz like sprint and
jump are at the same button where for
the games respectively reverse it in
this game yeah you're right so I think
this is it master master cool guys uh
hang out here throw an orb it's got to
be but it's it's either the bomb or
there is one of those orbs just nearby
right like yeah
what do we see
describe it to me describe it to me
thank you so Arctic right now I can't
change that
god I I need to get like I still am
missing so much stuff in this game dude
like I am missing Tom Cruise Mission
Possible - right here I'm know I'm
missing so much gear like I just I could
easily put another 60 hours into this
game I think happily and still keep
getting these stuff Peter Chavez what's
the problem you said this is horrible
what is so horrible
I'm having a great time me too I don't
know anyone I have an idea where this
orb is throw the orb what are you worth
going down there just to see you guys
going on I mean you die unless they
added something what is just a
bottomless pit
yeah trust me after help I'm sure you
asked me to trust you before dead that's
weird when did this come about why
didn't I notice this before this is
where you fight I told you yeah Master
Koga man down down oh oh
they know what's up have you seen an orb
beam up dude if you fight him again if
you fight him again I will lose my [ __ ]
big gaping hole Rob she said it are we
doing all this again
oh really yeah man boy remember remember
this I remember yeah so like what the
first time that I went into the implant
hideout it was so frustrating because I
didn't realize that there was supposed
to be like a wall yeah trying so many
times but I feel like now with that
knowledge and experience this might not
be that bad god damn it we're doing this
all again on second floor [ __ ] let me
use my big guns my upgraded master sword
ought to do the trick
[ __ ] what am I actually doing are we
going up here
she said second floor right I can't
remember what that would be well there
is the second floor up there okay cuz
you kind of come in on that little lake
I don't know we call it overhang I don't
know oh god you know what that means to
is that you're gonna have to pick it up
and probably walk backwards hopefully
these guys are done walk the heck words
well backtrack man for a second I
thought you don't cover it a secret room
great
sure why not
I don't have time for this [ __ ] hey guys
let's try to keep it civil in the chat
if you don't want to watch this game you
don't have to yeah that's within your
willpower to get to get out of here
but we encourage you to stick around man
we should have gone into plan oh that
wasn't tight show yourselves yeah it's
pretty great
nice work look at you
I'm just not last time we did this it
was it did not go well I'm just not
having those rupees Oh cuz we know we're
doing is we're doing on master mode - oh
you are we know we did oh I was like if
this is master mode
I am flummoxed now an insect huh I'm
wasting these and I want icon still hot
what's up good to see you we are playing
standard play yeah you can always tell
master mode with the bottom left-hand
corner is a little white small Triforce
right cool sweet do it
Oh Oh
so do you have every single piece of
gear jeez this point although I guess
you don't have something I had earlier
but it's not that important the warm
Buble yeah I never got it
never saw that old band he was like he
was up but like at the snow shrine in
the kind of the early tutorial ones oh
here's your type is easier than I
thought
kind of glad I just killed those dudes
to be honest yeah I'm so glad that that
you said it too like like that weapon
you have in the beginning of this DLC
and like do you have no what you asked
like do you have no health and like that
weapon the entire time I was like no
it's like thank God because that was so
difficult that's why I do the trick
hello billionaire boy that's a fantastic
name isn't that fantastic that's
fantastic
that shrine looks different I had like a
growth spurt or something you know
nailed it
I've been listening a lot to the sound
to the sound track a lot retune yeah
it's it's super subtle like when you're
playing the game you've got so many
other things you're paying attention to
but when you are just like outside of
the game in real life like say trying to
write or something you put it on so good
yeah and definitely a lot of the
overworld type stuff too yeah like I'm
definitely not listening to any of the
like combat action songs like The
Guardian ones because those don't ever
bring good feelings no Guardian oh yeah
I am getting pretty into the it's the
same as the Eventide song the one that
that that plays when you're using that
that new wand for the first four trials
yeah all the Lost Woods yes yes I see oh
dude so good yeah so how's my attempt
all right so so how I remember these
from the past where's that after the
fact oh please God don't be what I think
it is yeah we needed more of this oh
yeah okay we'll come back it's probably
right people love hearing that
[Music]
all right I'm assuming this is gonna
align with any of these but we got to
find a number for each one well well
well well alright what you got what you
got here oh we got a it's a guessing
game how many are in here alright so
let's see there's definitely only one
orange cool we actually know there are
definitely two you don't have to
actually do any kind of like puzzles
with this we've got a live inside
alright let's stick with green I'm
seeing two green are some of them like
massed some of the master [ __ ] I'm
seeing two green let's try to knock out
two of these before we leave okay
two green but then there's one that's
like maybe green yeah too orange
I shake it up all right all right all
right all right so I'm seeing four
purple okay to orange to green one red
for purple to orange to green to green
whoa wait what color is this red how
many red was that one
three green Thomas Holloway holy [ __ ]
whoops you get three ah yeah whatever I
believe him and how about these perps Oh
danke
perps I think there were two to pick one
and not for definitely not for it's four
five okay
[Laughter]
three green did we do three yeah yeah we
did all right all right again all right
all right all right let's look again
wait I need my glasses yeah definitely
one red
oh those the ones that like look like
they're mashed they're just see-through
so there'd meant to confuse you
there's four purple four perps four
parts how many how many orange there
I still say - yeah one red three green
how many would we say with purple I'm
sorry for four chip third green bird
bird bird was it green that we get we
got wrong three green maybe megazord I'm
kicking you out dude we don't need any
of that [ __ ] in this chat so please do
not do that
[Music]
what'd we get wrong - yellow yellow I'll
have some of the yellow maybe that's it
damn it
1 2 - orange one red or purple to green
yeah yeah I think it's to orange and -
[Laughter]
nailed it nailed it yeah what's up he j
PK thunder I'm sorry it's been a long
morning morning
it's been a long last week it has been a
long last week and it's just getting
started I mean it's not even close to
over
you got what PSX happening tonight [ __ ]
it starts at 8:00 p.m.
I wish you told me after this string
Weiner wayna we did it no kiss me my
hand has been in this position for a
while that's beginning to hurt I'm
cramping I look dope as [ __ ] oh thank
you so much link see ya ship skipped us
golly golly jeez no thanks Albert Lee
Ellison we really enjoy doing this
because our normal work is not this fun
no I want to talk to them
hey remember when you told me not to
throw that in there I guess why did I
throw them in the hole dude throw them
both in there I'd love to be judge and
jury is this the couple that you always
save we're just getting their asses
kicked by both oblems yeah actually I
think the motorcycle is in the hole
mm-hmm react there huh all right cool
let's get the hell out of here groovy
tell you what what up how far you in
master mode oh damn we're going to the
divine beast yo how far am I in master
mode yes
what is this Southern gentleman thing
you've got going on here I don't know I
don't know I I might my goal was to do
mask the trials of the sword but got my
ass handed to me yeah and I need more
hearts so I think I want to say I'm like
I got full stamina and I want to say I
mean how many hearts do I have right now
Jesus so many I'm like I'm like halfway
I want to say it's like max two parts so
I was like knocking out shrines but I
swear to god this games just distracts
the hell out of you so I really don't
know what I'm doing
well Phoenix Washington and YouTube chat
doesn't know how he got here but thank
you for joining us Felix Washington it's
good to have you you're home now all
right
what up Benja I'm here okay what now and
those bats want to tell you a secret
I'm listening damn dude all right
Melo Mike oh wow
k RS to the sequel to Karis woman claims
deep purple is better than Led Zeppelin
Robyn get out of here
whoa that's just that is just wrong
that's an opinion but it's just wrong
Bob Jones good to have you as always man
what are we up to today well I don't
know maybe a little game called Zelda
DLC you've got another goddamn this
they're gonna do something here
Rob's feeling real angsty right now yeah
I am lack of sleep Linc ate something
bad far something something is that
because we're Hylian mushrooms Lincoln
oh my god I really don't want another
type of trial that limits me it's like
doodies do these puzzles with no legs
controls are reversed or your arms four
legs pull out the blindfold from the DLC
packet and put on your would you look at
you oh that's hot that fit is so sweet
gonna do that Michael Scott quote he's
he's hitting on one of the co-workers
and he's trying to make her feel like
she's attractive you think you know what
I think you're giving me a boner oh no I
love that show I'll sleep to it
just kidding it's me Ravalli you thought
it was Elba wait so is this
they're back this guy was the hardest
one dude oh you know what this is it's
like you're reliving your Bose has
memories like when she got her ass
kicked by the stuff I want to say and
I'm that's happenin to me right now oh
damn this guy's actually won the tougher
ones I just said I'm sorry I was
thinking I also just said that all right
oh damn I really don't have much put on
your rubber suit boy no I don't have
their lighter Bob Jones you don't have
that damn it Bob Jones good advice oh
all right
show that turd who's boss
just okay get rid of Perry baby that's
what you got to do you ever had a
perfect pairing oh yeah oh [ __ ] oh man
Wow the trying I think I think I just
got a mess up his shield than that yeah
it's been a while since I played this
dude been Jalil katie's so far it's
pretty cool I think you know I can speak
for Rob here we just love being in this
world so much and any excuse to get back
in and do something new even if it's not
like a groundbreaking new experience in
the game it just kind of makes us happy
I mean there's everything about being
these environments moving listening to
the music and facing new challenges it's
just so so we're super stoked to have
something sure not say that it's
flawless or anything but it's kind of
hard to feel too bad about its minor
grievances it's just so damn good and
the fact that what 20 bucks for this and
master mode and brows of the sword right
oh that's an incredible deal I mean this
game is worth so much more to me in its
base state than 60 bucks
that
like yeah I will so I will support games
like this up and down nice work protip
just hit him a lot it's a big thanks
good yeah man I this is this has been
already enough content for me I think I
think 20 bucks is a deal yeah holy I'm
super lucky I'm not a person who usually
cares about autographs but I was able to
get my copy of the game autographed by
the director fujibayashi the art
director and the environment designer
during GDC and I'm that for me is to
sort of I don't know I really don't care
about getting things autographed ever
but this games meant so much to me about
having those names on there it just
brings me a lot of joy
yes zero HX co seven in the YouTube chat
a lot of people feel that this game
suffered from maybe a lack of classic
Zelda elements even the dungeons
themselves didn't really fit the mold
and that is a and it's just you know
what people like Zelda games for
different reasons I actually think the
dungeons were kind of unnecessary in
this game and I would have been happy
without them thank you it's been a while
sorry
someone said use matte oh yeah [ __ ]
didn't mean to do that sorry I
distracted you good doing your thing
again but uh but you know I don't even
though I say that the dungeons and stuff
had the classic Zelda elements in the
game aren't that important to this
experience for me I would still like a
new classic Zelda game to come out but I
wouldn't necessarily want to sacrifice
this new direction for Zelda or the
other I think they can they can coexist
in different games see what nintendon't
is next I I'm sort of of the mind that
they're gonna do another round of DLC
for this game next year it's something I
think it's gonna be another two years or
so before they even give a hint to a new
Zelda game they've got such a great
platformer here all they need to do is
extend the map a little bit we already
know time travel isn't in the game let
me go somewhere else and do something
like totally possible Rob you got this
good everyone in the chat is cheering
for you definitely you guys have finally
this guy
God dang it move let's go man
I can't I can't heal I don't have
anything I can't yeah it's a trial I'm
sorry let's do that again
don't be sorry man you did not expect
any of that only anyone can blame you I
was impressed you got that far I know
what to do now
I'll be quicker why are you giggling
just cuz that was just such a disaster I
love it
I'm coming back for you
like average man I think that's a fair
critique to identifying classic Zelda
but really it's you know the original
Zelda that model was left behind for the
most part until we got back to breath of
the wild some what so you know I think
most Zelda games between then and now
really did follow what we now at least I
am referring to as the classic Zelda
experience before you claim I'm too
young the original Zelda was one of the
first video games I ever played so I'm
with you I'm with you I know how this
series began
all right let's breathe breathe in
through that okay well you see the
little tips like that
what's Rach I feel you
thunder thunder blood I feel you you're
here skip I know what you're all about
let's party
come down here there you are
I know your tricks No you killed my
champion friends and I want revenge
I'll give you one and that's it that's
all you get Thunder boy all right -
that's fine well you're quick
you're quick he's easily the hardest oh
by far the other one dear I see yeah
it's the only one that really
you're doing your dumb move do it miss
me it'll be like magnet magnets link
whoops
kind of on point there Thomas Adams this
is uh you know fighting this over again
but same time you are sort of limited in
the equipment that you get to use so
change the challenge a little bit not as
cool if it was entirely new boss fights
but we certainly don't know at least Rob
and I don't know the full extent well
this DLC has because we do expect
come on Jesus holy guacamole
I'll say can we get back up first Rob
apparently the entire Internet is
cheering for you I don't like your
sarcasm I don't want to do your pari
just let's do this let's do that fight
again though we were doing earlier quiet
dude this Rob does this thing where he
goes like that now we have to huh oh
cool
no come on
okay see Electrify
No
I have to Sheila go okay you can get all
these down boys up yes dude my heart oh
I did not want to do that again I'm
sorry I my lack of skills did it you
know it's like I can't he's so fast it's
hard to get your Sherlock back on them
to get your shield out yeah and you
hesitated for a minute right
that's gross so I don't have to do that
again me too yeah that was that was a
good mushroom pique if I held my ground
and blocked I get shocked though yeah
electrocution and in
[Music]
[Music]
sweet how'd you feel about the Game
Awards last night I was fun I liked this
trailer
it's pretty dope I'm glad to see being
in us coming back to princess of Hyrule
I accept your proposition without
position as a Titian not only are they
planning to resurrect calamity Ganon
it seems the Jaeger clan is also after
our treasured heirloom you have my word
I won't rest until the calamity stop
caleb is for joining us thank you
my boss is it this just got frenches
[ __ ] we're looking for an orb there you
go
phantom
yeah you're badass yeah average man that
was kind of stoked by the bayonetta
announcement especially after games like
scalebound a platinum like platform
holder publisher funded games but beyond
free it's also bringing one and two back
because I swear to God I don't want to
buy Wii U just to play some of those
games I never actually owned one and I'm
just really happy I don't have that pose
said was freakin hilarious you asked me
why I call you little bird huh when you
were but a small child my dear friend
called you that with the sweetest smile
that ever graced our land of Hyrule
[Music]
it was ten long years ago your mother
had just left this world Oh give us a
Firebird still spread her wings and
became the beacon of light hyrule needed
chirp-chirp sometimes I forget myself
[Music]
speaking of bringing an ocarina of time
and majora's mask to switch yes please
do that but please base them Nintendo
off of the 3ds versions which were not
remakes more like remasters and their
slightly improved and look a little bit
better
I would love to play those games on a
bigger screen how do you get the
motorbike I have no idea we're doing it
it's the reward you get for completing
all he said he's pretty sure someone
said he said it on stage here in the
office Oh
yeah average man transfer over his
destruction was supposed to be pretty
wait a second oh hello hello hello
upgraded we've got an upgraded ability
tight tight so tight let's try it out on
cast it transfers the suction supposed
to be pretty good I didn't get a chance
to play that but you know another Wii U
game from platinum I really want on
switch because I didn't really get a
chance to play as much of it as I wanted
to is the wonderful in a1 that's a game
that seems like it will not come back oh
dang it's sad
dang it's got some it's got some spread
now that was really far spread it on all
right what's up next
hey what's up guys hey what's up guys
we're gonna be tackling the next one I
think give me an adventure
okay figures so I just realized I did
the hardest one first I think that's I
would imagine right that thunder blight
is a real POS real thunder what's next
what you want to do next
of gowest Ravalli good cop ain't it
link you want to go in my head and see
where I've been well if you can handle
it
do you want to come inside this brain of
mine and see my thoughts Ravalli here
come take a look at my memories link if
you so dad did you know that I can fly
like oh you can't mm-hmm
figures mmm watch me do a barrel roll
link you wanna come inside my brain and
look at my memories
oh hey link you just caught me flying in
midair while eating my breakfast you
know I didn't actually need to die way
back there sounds like fun to be honest
I was just kind of bored with Hyrule and
everything had had to offer so I I kind
of let myself die you just can't contain
me you could've ravioli ravioli Ravalli
he would have his own line of pasta
coming dude a little guy
I should be mid-area now Oh
I'm imagining like food commercials or
each of its champions like play off each
other the rooks Donuts are the right
thing to get your day started when I'm
not riding my divine beast around here
call a region you dare I'm sure I'm
eating my group doughnuts get me fueled
in the morning God
the roofs ready to roll into your mouth
stupid oh thank you for watching her
Dumbo
oh you just caught me rolling my dough
for doughnuts just swaps out lyrics from
his teacher wasn't gonna write his own
stuff my teacher taught me this let's
hear some of your own tracks shoot the
flame dragon's horn
I missed that okay
[Music]
no no what if Cass is gaining the whole
time that would be amazing I would love
that that's that's the twist that would
just make my brain explode for the scag
woman I wouldn't be able to handle it
what if link is gaming the whole thing
all right crazy smack out we get out
let's take a look at these photos thanks
for joining us
sushi Sid good to have you here should
have all of you here mm-hmm mm-hmm
all right oh I know what this is
describe it to me actually I kind of do
we are back with Triforce man like me
and Rob used to do this show feels like
forever ago we played this dumb little
game see what big dumb [ __ ] we can do
it's been fun so far I'm having a grand
old time I love this game you used that
sounds very believable really it was
genuine let you go to Toronto peak
Toronto cold snap it sounds like a nice
beer yeah I think it's right actually
like on the shrine thanks to pro gamer
for joining us and for subscribing to us
right remember that show about dinosaurs
you bet your ass I remember the show
Dino DNA literally titled dinosaurs oh
wait yeah Dino DNA you mean that's yeah
I'm at the TV show that was a ripoff of
Family Matters oh god I miss that show
was weird
all right mama oh my god
I was listening to a podcast recently
which I'll give a shout out to 30 2010
the guys over at the lazer time network
Chris santista Dave redden sometimes
Henry Gilbert Diana Goodman they all do
really great work over there
they have a podcast 30 2010 where they
look at pop culture in the past did a
great little analysis show dinosaurs I'd
like to hear that it is it's so we're
the baby dinosaurs just a weird-looking
thing right and not to mention the fact
that it was like an incredibly expensive
show to make sure there's all practical
effects right and those suits were half
robotic half like suits and but the
people actually couldn't see so like the
number of takes they had to do for
anyone like handing an object from one
character to another just like start
cutting those out as the show continued
to fail all right help me out here I'm
thinking yeah I think I think it's
around here yeah I knew that Konami
bridge right on that ledge no no no no I
think it's here no I think you'll figure
it out there it shall reveal itself
what's up Sammy mania for joining us now
this is an easy one I grew up here a
giant hole right sure right sure oh
that's that doc so that's right around
here oh that's it and a bingo was his
name-o flight range so you do some
midair firing oh you know it dude that's
a good call let's go up here first Oh
0hx e07 yeah
they had like a Gundam like you could
wear and pilot a small divine beast I
was like a mech I'm pretty dope I would
rather have that than a motorcycle that
reminds me of like Xenoblade Chronicles
X yeah that was a really significant
thing when he can't be mixed in that
game just a holy hell how cool would
that be that song they play whenever you
like they played it in that trailer when
you get the bike done
linked wearing a mech suit or if all the
divine beasts could like Voltron into
one divine just massive hell yeah yeah I
almost yeah you know that was probably a
thought I got that thing that's
cool-looking
imagine waiting in line in front of that
or like he said he sitting in front of
you a movie theater could you take that
off
no hey who's up for a game of leapfrog
not with that dude
greetings from Mars holy [ __ ] I didn't
know they had YouTube on Mars
sorry distracted we're speedrunning this
earlier for us do you for hours be
running yeah oh yeah I know we we
destroyed records dude this is great I
know exactly what we're about to do now
nope oh okay yeah baby oh man is that my
ghost
link I'm Way faster than you beat my
time slow [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you call that shield certain [ __ ] wax my
board come on
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] no no shred the gnar fresh
powder Lee no it's it's fine I can wait
as long as you're shredding gnar excuse
me where's your lift pass link I've been
waiting for a hundred years
go for it
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] me right leg yeah sure do
whatever you want that mean is all-time
best for it's like Nick I've been
waiting for a hundred years where are
you it's Mario Kart deluxe and he's like
in ER he's in the small as Mario Kart
it's like his eyes are rolling just
ready to go and erase it where are you
what have you been doing how similar is
the bike cuz I know in Mario Kart
it's got like that horse head
I wonder how similar that is to this one
like structurally designs did you just
see that Bo I did you just see that run
I had that was a killer time time time
it's noon I don't need food
I've already had what's up Dale sorry no
forget it
I didn't want to tell everyone what I
ate today either food no oh yeah I like
these it's like a little game of
mousetrap remember those old games like
in the late 80s where you had like it
was like a box with like a thing you'd
have to tilt and like move the ball
around oh yeah yeah yeah no but you
don't see those anymore no at least I
don't not with these eyes no those are
definitely not around
everyone anybody just doesn't have a
screen maybe maybe maybe how do we mana
a polite motion Jeff oh geez I don't
know oh man this is gonna be interesting
all right so I can already tell you this
much I have to do this
yes all right
Oh
there's things Pierce whoa you know I
just initially was trying was a ground
pound and then a jump up mari isn't that
rich rich and compelling oh I know
exactly how to do this okay then no I
can do it like no come on why are you
stuck
dennah no Falcon great this is easily
one of the most tedious things in the
game guy sorry mr. twelve
why would I drop more tedious how about
my other Falcon bow more tedious than
the sword yeah it's just more this is
just like you should be able to replace
an item supposed to like oh oh yeah I
didn't I did not explain myself I
thought you meant this budget no like
you should be able to like swap an item
yeah and like not go through the
animation again yeah but that is kind of
one of those things about this game for
all for all the little stuff that they
did right that you never expected just a
couple it's kind of like basic thing
it's not at all but it's just like I
almost I almost feel like they're like
they're so pretentious about it look no
it's totally justifiable we're not gonna
change it look at the they won't admit
it I wonder how they feel about the
success of this game like obviously
they're happy that it doesn't work right
but like when they're considering it is
it like hey guys this is a sign they're
confident and our ideas we know what
we're doing let's be
or is it like [ __ ] we're gonna do this
again how are we gonna match crash game
which is already so big and full of
ideas and even some of the stuff at GDC
that they were talking about what they
were like oh these are some of the crazy
ideas well we see one of the motorcycle
the only one we haven't really seen that
they were showing off I can recall
anyway it was the presence of like UFOs
and aliens maybe that's maybe if my
hunch is correct and there is gonna be
deals to next year it'll be
Kanan actually came here on a meteor or
comment I don't know they pull a crystal
school on that
hopefully I can get to it before No
come on come out I lost it
let's play the game dude dude
okay you're good Oh
Oh No Oh No
rats
yeah gooo the only motion control stuff
we saw so far was it was king of the box
and it was tasteful yes it was the only
the only way I would ever have motion
controls was how they did it there it
was just like God the most rush anything
was why I was replaying and I mastered
remote some of those things where I'm
handheld and I'm like hurting my wrist
cuz I'm upside down like trying to get
it just right man I'm really messing
this up I'm not paying attention all
right he's doing pretty well for second
sure good point
Oh Star Wars in the chat no don't even
start what you mean I'm I can't I can't
have to sell the DLC and Star Wars going
through my mind at some time I'll
explode
I've got a bad feeling about this
oh no do it baby
yeah yeah come on come on yeah nice why
are those a bunch of eggplants in the
chat there yes that's good stuff Michael
like sumela Mike hey listen that never
gets old
yeah right
[Music]
this guy should eat something you like
uh potatoes I got mushrooms I mean I
cook man I can cook a damn good mati
banana you have no idea
add a little like mighty thistle mesh it
little dragon skill hmm baby you gonna
attack buff going is there also a map
expansion with this DLC hell no
unfortunately lease not that we've seen
yet I mean you like in the beginning you
revisit the great plateau and it's
different they like added like big dead
trees that you climb on and like enemy
types they changed up a little bit but
ultimately note some big dead trees here
oh ship it perfect no no there there is
some stuff or I should say some
locations where you can still like climb
up and then the game is like no sorry
dude we don't want you to go up here mmm
I still hold out hope there's more to
this game maybe not what this DLC make
down the road
there was a I want to say it was like
they like re-released a collector's
edition or something that people in like
that I like on the sub read and stuff at
the end they talked about the expansions
and they they refer to this as one
expansion the DLC pack 1 & 2 and they
like in bold like like pluralized that
expansion it's like nothing to like go
crazy over but it was interesting how
they phrase it and a sense of like it's
not the expansion yeah like we have like
here is one of the expansions though we
are confirming like right now it was
kind of insinuating it would be silly to
abandon this got such an awesome
foundation here yeah absolutely man just
like the like the physics system alone
you know I mean they're like there's so
many moving parts that like you can go
crazy with I'm really curious to see
what they do with that bike I mean
regardless how you feel about it the
bike being and they're like you know to
what extent does it like feel
comfortable right like can you do a flip
can you do moves with it like similar to
like shield surfing how does it even
like work against terrain a binding like
stasis right like shoot can you shoot
off of it can you again like any kind of
tricks it looked like it had some sort
of like because it's like a unicorn with
like a thing happen in charge Oh char
something all right keep your eyes
peeled Chris Jones with the hot takes in
YouTube saying the Lost legacy in
horizon zero dawn are better than this
game prizes Jared daun is damn good
Lost legacy in my mind it's pretty good
this game is phenomenal
I should have taken a picture
we're looking for a shrine Oh dinner all
good to see you
Carl we like Billy Madison I want I want
a piece of your horn man never seen
these for the first time
whoa oh that's uh yeah Peter let's take
a look at this shoot the flame dragons
horn okay you can do it I'm gonna pull
up my big guns sniper
[Laughter]
Eric green you missed us both doing an
impression of Ravalli it's too bad
turns out Ravalli chose to die because
this world is just boring hmm what's
that for Valley here give me some that
horn dude
dragons like all right cool I'm out of
here
dude dude your book curtain that orange
oh yeah you like that skill you should
probably get those decades nuts seeds
this is this is why this game is so damn
distracting how far do I have to go oh
no that's perfect have you uh kept up on
the mortgage on your house like I don't
have my bod and everything take your
house your paint you're being worried Oh
God
you're not paying a mortgage no damn it
then you're lucky cuz I'm back goddamn
it dude I gotta pay those all right
let's Tom Cruise this you say that for
everything I'm sorry solo student yes it
is ravioli not Ravalli people making
mortgage jokes what have I done
mortgage free man oh boy
Oh Oh perfect
[ __ ] you
one of the things that struck me about
this game when I first started playing
it is how much it reminded me of
Princess Mononoke the two aren't it's
not like a direct inspiration at least
important to dads I just read watched
that movie recently I should watch it
have you ever seen it I know I know the
animation style and everything though it
is I want you to come over my house and
watch it okay it's crying right now it's
so it's so good it is like like you know
okay you think about Ghibli films right
like spirited away stuff like that it's
like it's like so far out there and
creative and like intricate fine
whatever princess mononoke tells a
incredibly dramatic and like seemingly
powerful story where there is no like
the character who is the villain she's
she's great she's not black she's not
white like there's no evil or good thing
like she has reasons for doing things
that you perceive as evil but she still
does things that make her perhaps one of
the more generous people in the entire
conflict like it's it's crazy it's just
you know you talking about that you know
in this game your relationship to nature
exists with Princess Mononoke just
doubles down on all of that and so many
of the visual cues that were inspired by
sort of like very old Japanese history
and cultures are present in that film as
well
Donelson I'm talking about Mononoke he
may make a a princess mononoke damn I
really want to do that it's it's like
along with the Kiera it's one of my
favorite movies of all time and is in my
opinion the most impressive at the best
such everything by a wide margin I got
the shrine in my sights
yes right do not watch the dub Billy Bob
Thornton plays a character Billy Crudup
please the main characters that I don't
know but he's emotional I mean I'd I
know the name I don't know like who he
is like I've taught my head he just
plays like the most deadpan emotionless
character it sucks hey Dee was done
someone had a question about yeah robo
says fury I don't know if it has a
second charge it's just bigger well I
could find out actually it's it's got
like definitely I would say like oh uh
cuz I never use a lot of those abilities
maybe Ravalli scale once in a while yeah
but you find out like this so if it was
just one before
it's two now but I can't remember Eric
green asking about vampire hunter D
which is relevant to gaming in that the
lead artist behind it yoshitaka amano is
the concept artist for Final Fantasy and
has been vampire hunter D the original
film kind of looks like [ __ ] today but
it's still very interesting for its
atmosphere the second one the they're
like 2000 2001 was like a blood lust or
something like that
couldn't get into it not for me but I do
love the art style just like in the
concept art 4d that stuff is pretty rad
I actually had this big art book it's
about this big
that's about all I'd say my man that's
about all I'll say about that must have
had me about 13 dr. peppers gotta go pay
aim for stillness this may have to be
the last thing we do and I know I know
you can keep playing but I I gotta go
play cuz I got to review this game but
you're getting all the hot tricks
because I'm a super sad
hot is correct because it is damn pot
yeah you're the smart guy not wearing
that's how I like it
[Music]
oh my shrine all right well you got here
bombs away boom this game whoops let's
do that again now's fine
I kind of figured he was gonna go in
there gotcha
all the wind and kite stuff as far as
those shrines were I think some of my
favorites oh this is an unusual mechanic
nope
Oh No
ready
Oh oh wait no I'm getting that wrong all
right oh now I get it
I believe in you
I know what I'm doing
yeah start just shy don't go
I know you can't wait
it's what sucks is that I'm actually
turning now yes
I'm turning when no later I'm like
turning not with it so I have to like
readjust now damn it
you know what I really could do you know
I could do
[Music]
great
it's all chefs over here me go get
Jesus God nope
a little more no it's kind of tricky oh
you know I can do I'll go back here I'll
just go up from there just do that
probably they want me to do anyways
sweat yeah
open up now son
oh I think I have to redo all this by
die huh I'm not gonna die then right I
don't haven't died those earlier ones
that's the case I don't know about these
actually so it was weird like some of
those earlier shrines in this DLC like
depending on where I died oh yeah there
were a few of them had checkpoints for
sure yeah it would make me run across
the room to hit a switch every time I
played but if I killed one enemy by
going down but I'd never have
oh my go earlier yeah
all great pickup okay now this is good
didn't
shower up this dream
I want that bike Peter you're doing it
Peter you can fly you can fight I
actually watched why it is pretty good
it was like the second movie in a row
they're like no crap I watched some
jingle all the way last night there two
nights ago and that would be the third
movie in a row where it was like a dad
who is like on the phone like on four
different phones like talking to a
secretary like don't worry honey I'll be
there I won't miss the sons thing I know
it's very important and there's no
making a call hello honey you are my
favorite customer wait honey no my
number-one customer I don't know what or
how I'm supposed to do that
sorry stream yes it's cuz the wind
lura is causing him to get close yeah
but so do I go earlier
I suppose yes I measure my important
scoop by the number of phones I have
within reach in any given time
you can't stay cyst that and you can't
that's what I'm saying you got I think
you gotta stasis that right before yeah
that's it
Wow
I swear to God that's always the key yes
I go to that chasse to finish it
get that chest better be good
they won't be you got an ancient spring
you got air ten arrows you got water
right now I'm running low I'll take it
I'll take what I can get
what's to say is like there's so many
times where you just whenever you hit I
feel like you hit a roadblock in this
game it's always because you're not
thinking about your freakin state your
roots it's like oh of course
like even like you haven't already
without what Thunder black guy yeah what
am I suppose to be doing there's like oh
of course that gooses nice you did it
homie whoo well I want my ten minutes
back I can't give that back to you it's
literally impossible yeah Rob I'm gonna
pull out the cameras so we can say
goodbye okay I gotta go
are you keep playing I don't I don't I
don't think so maybe what we should do
next week we I'll get the bike today if
not tomorrow and then maybe Monday we'll
do like a 2 p.m. stream and just tear up
I rule on that bike really appreciate
everyone tuning in today on twitch and
YouTube and on GameSpot's if you want to
hear more from us you can follow Rob on
Twitter at what's your Twitter handle
Rob Robert Hilary is that it yes I'm
crazy like that I'm a PC Brown stay
tuned next week because we will start to
announce our game of the Year winners
starting with number 10 on Monday and so
then have a great weekend have fun
playing Zelda if you get the chance and
as always thanks for tuning in take care
is this the outro button I don't know
what I'm doing